last time I saw you you had the tree
trunk you had the tree branches lighter
and now it's like I went a big I went I
went all in and like I may be paying the
price a little too much shoulda brought
a towel how many people in the cast and
crew do you actually get to kick it with
because you're just voicing over stuff I
get to kick it with a few of them
probably my favorite in the whole cast
are the closest of my family is Zoe
Saldana
hence avatar hence why I'm doing avatar
or one of the reasons but um yeah you
know I I'm always torn you know it's a
it's much as I can celebrate Avengers
right now I've got fast coming in 2020
seen the picture we got a grind man we
got a grind but this sweat is good but
we do it in the love and in the name of
cosplay all those guys out there when
you come into this premiere you see so
many people invested they created
costumes they're wearing it out there in
the intense heat and I felt like jumping
in with them I'm being a part at rapping
with them to the BARC group jacket we
get that line start the line